Wow.
So good to be here.
I,
uh,
I grew up in Palo alto
long before Google existed.
And then, uh, I, uh,
in Ed Palo Alto High,
I was in class,
it was the same year as a lease
and Brendan Jobs, Steve Jobs,
his daughter and we were
on the newspaper together,
the camping Neely and my teacher,
uh,
Esther would jet ski.
We called her watch,
then became the
mother-in-law of Sergei Brin.
So like my teacher is like
the mother-in-law volatile.
Yeah.
Or the ex mother x a mother.
But I hear from the New York Times
article that they're, they're all good,
that they, they go to the met ball
together. It's still and all that.
So well,
welcome James Franco to Google.
Okay.
Move off a toxic Google and
we'll get right into it. So
thanks for being here. Uh,
so your new film, the disaster artist,
which is based on, uh, tell me why Zos uh,
weird film the room. Yes.
It's the making. Yes.
The room is a cultural,
we'll just classic cult hit.
It's really weird. When, when
did you first see the room?
I was really late to the room.
Um,
it's been out for a 14
and a half years now. Uh,
he, the story is, he made it,
came out in 2003,
uh,
he intended it to be
this great drama. Um, uh,
he wrote on the poster Tennessee
Williams level drama, uh,
which kind of shows what he's aiming for.
Uh,
it cost $6 million of his own money.
Where he got is a,
is a big mystery and uh, it's
so weird. Oh, marina. Yeah,
my phone.
We are,
Lorena and I were jogging this
morning just when we arrived here.
We didn't go, we just like
went one direction, uh,
just aimless, sort of started at the, at
the Ritz and jog all the way down to um,
beat street. And he would always,
Tommy would always say, well,
I made my $6 million from
a selling Levi's jeans.
And he actually got into
the screen actors guild, um,
by financing his own commercial for
his denim jeans outlet called street
fashions. And I know it cause we read,
we recreated and the disaster is,
but we ended up not using it, but
he, um, you can find it online. Uh,
just Google it. Uh, he uh,
is wearing like a renaissance hat and
he's quoting amylase is too big or not to
be, that is the question. Come to street
fashions can get Levi's jeans, five, five,
five beat street
and Lorena and I jogged and all of us,
we just went into straight line.
All of a sudden I look
up and there's this,
this is just like three hours ago I look
up and there's this poster of him in
the room. I'm like, oh look what a great
sign. And then I realized, oh my gosh,
it was like five, five, five beach street.
But we couldn't find the
thing all we could find his,
his poster and this big
Levi's jeans thing. Anyway,
he, yeah, he so I'm sorry you
asked me to a whole other question.
It's freshman, you got to
find out. I just ramble.
It's cost $6 million. It
made $1,800. Its first run.
People from the premiere on,
we're laughing at it. Um,
and unlike other,
you know,
directors that have these movies that
have become colt hit because they're so
bad or because people like to
laugh at them, like troll to, um,
Tommy had the wherewithal to kind of
capitalize on that and rewrite history.
So where he was completely
oblivious to how he was
coming off to other people.
As soon as people started
laughing at the movie,
he just became a maestro.
Like is as much as he lacked
self awareness before.
He then was like a car dashing with like
the way he can capitalize on publicity.
And, um, and he put it
in one theater in La, uh,
the sense of five and to
plate it midnights and it
just sorta caught on with USC
film students and then built it,
built from there.
He paid another bit of Tommy
and sanity's he paid for,
or maybe genius he'd paid for
this billboard on Highland. Um,
what was his face?
And it was that same image was like,
what the lazy eyelid and it said the room.
And then there was a phone number.
And, uh, I must have drove, you
know, he kept it up for five years.
That's hundreds of dollars, thousands of
dollars right there, you know, and, uh,
I must've driven past that hundreds of
times and just thought it's a colt or,
you know, I, I ran into a friend the
other day, he's like, oh yeah, that thing.
I thought it was a wanted
poster or something. And, uh,
so that's all I knew of the room for
years and years. And then four years ago,
the book came out that was written by,
um,
one of the other actors,
Greg says,
Terah who my brother plays in the movie
and this really great journalists,
Tom Bissell. And I was just blown
away. It was just, you know,
it was, um, I love Hollywood stories
and this was unlike any other,
and I'm just, cause it was so
bizarre row on the surface,
but at the same time it was, you know,
it was the story of anyone, you know,
uh, with a dream, you know, the story
of, I'm sure the, the, you know,
surrogates story. I mean the
passion behind it, I'm sure
you know, they, they were,
you know, at one point there are
people who were like, why Google?
What is that thing? You
know what I mean? Like,
and here he was like
anyone with a dream and uh,
he made it out.
I'll be it like very ironically,
but it still had sort of the underpinnings
of a kind of Hollywood success story.
It was interesting watching the movie
and then coming out of it and thinking
about it.
It's like he came into it thinking this
is going to be the best movie ever made,
but it was the worst movie. Yeah.
Which made it the best movie.
And then you're making a movie. It's a
phenomenal film about a terrible film.
That's a really good film.
Like it's very confusing how it kind
of all come and together I'm like,
it kind of blows your mind.
Sets would say James Franco
and I'm the only one that like came to
the room through the book. That's awesome.
Very James Franco. But uh, yes, it,
it was bizarre. We w we were talking
about it over the past month.
We couldn't come up with a of another
example of a movie where the director of
the movie was acting in it,
playing a director who's acting in his
own movie and then sort of stayed in
character while he was directing.
That was my next question.
So you did stay in character
while you're directing. Yes,
but like there's this great documentary
out now I'm on Netflix called a Jiminny
Indiana. It's Andy Kaufman
or it's Jim Carrey when he's
playing Andy Kaufman. And,
um, it's an interview, you know,
recently was from recently with,
with Jim,
but it's also footage from 20 years ago
when he was doing the movie and he goes
so far in the Andy
Kaufman and his alter ego,
a Tony Clifton that Jim disappears
and like Milos foreman, you know,
one of the greatest directors ever who
did cookies nest. Nama Daz is like cow,
you know, by like there's Tony Clifton
character, he's like, you know,
really gruff kind of lounge
singer type and, and,
and it's like, you can't talk to Jim.
Like you see people like, Hey Jim,
that was great today. And he's like,
no, no, no. I'm Andy, I'm Andy.
You know Andy going so far that like,
you know, uh, uh, ambulance
was called and, and you know,
just like it's all this stuff going on
behind the scenes that doesn't even make
it into a man on the moon.
It says if he was like doing all this
stuff for this documentary 20 years later,
like I didn't do that. You
know what I mean? I didn't go,
I directed is James is just
filtered through the, you know,
funny voice and all across sites.
But like Tommy's direction
was absurd. Like we read
it, you know, you know,
Greg would tell us like when he was
auditioning people, he'd be like,
okay, uh, your sister
lesbian and she just die, go
Yay or no.
Or
that's literally what he said. So like I
wasn't doing that. You know what I mean?
I didn't go that far.
It was just sort of the voice.
Can you describe your first
meeting with Tommy? Like,
cause he's very good traction. They'll
be the first meeting with time. It,
what was that like? Or when did you
first meet him? So you got this,
you saw the book, right? You read the
book if you're interested in the room.
So then you w what's the Tom? And, um, I,
uh, here's the deal.
I've played, you know,
I think about eight or nine characters
that are based on real people.
They all have their own
requirements. You know, um, uh,
I played James Dean, who was a, you
know, one of Tommy's heroes. Um, I,
I played Aron Ralston who in one 27 hours
he got trapped by the Rock and cut his
arm off. And those have different
requirements. James Dean, you know,
because he was a, you know, an actor,
people can go to see his movies and
see what he looked like and moved,
how he moved and how he sounded
the same with Tommy. Right? So,
but with Aron Ralston, that's not
the case. Nobody, you know, yeah.
You can go online and look
them up, but his care, the,
the priority with that character
was capturing, you know,
with Aron Ralston is capturing like,
you know,
then tick experience to take the
audience on a ride of, you know,
really going through that.
Um,
with James Dean and Tommy, you
know, half of the, you know,
preparation is getting down, like all
the, the physical behavior and all that.
And then, and then trying to sort of, uh,
dig up what he was,
what's going on underneath.
Now Tommy is a particular kind of
mystery where he holds on to this facade.
It's a very thinly veiled facade
where he, you know, he say he,
he saw like this and you know,
he say from New Orleans and
like nobody believes him. I,
last night I was on Jimmy Kimmel
with Tommy, which was, you know,
the university has just exploded
right there. Like, you know,
the fact that he was on there,
but he strangely for the first time,
maybe in his entire life emitted and he
just tried to like slip it in. I was,
my brain was exploding and he was
like, you know, Jimmy was like,
where are you from Tommy?
He's like, well, you know,
I come from Europe and then I go to
New Orleans. I was like, wait, what?
You're admitting it and,
and you never heard that before.
That he never would say that,
you know, I'm, you know,
he had written reviews, you know,
not only did he say, you know,
when the movie came out, like a
Tennessee Williams level drama, he,
he wrote these fake reviews
like from like nine oh two went,
oh Beverly hills film review or
whatever. Like Tommy was, oh, the,
the raging Cajun delivers powerful,
like thriller is. Uh, and, uh, so no,
he had never said anything like
that before. Anyway, I had to,
I had to kind of get underneath
and figure out some of,
you know, what, maybe I could,
I could understand, okay,
he's from eastern Europe and you know,
I can, you know, get some of that stuff.
I didn't need that from Tommy,
but I couldn't go to
Tommy now and ask him,
you know, what was motivating
you when you're making the room?
Because he is the master
rewriter of history.
And now he claims that he
intended the room to be a comedy.
So, you know, when, in
fact she was not true,
incredibly sincere when he made it. Right.
So, you know, he says about the room now,
um, the room is safe place.
You can laugh, you can cry,
do whatever you like, just don't
hurt yourself, you know. Um,
so in that way he can still,
he can like take credit for being a
comedy but also that he's still greatest
director or you know, around. Um,
so I couldn't go to him as a source,
but what I had was, um, he would,
he would drive around in his car and I
know he was in his car cause I have the
recordings, I going to hear him like
doing the turn signal and everything like,
and he would talk to himself.
This is the nineties,
so it was like a mini tape recorder
who's talked to himself about all this
feelings about,
you know,
acting classes and being mistreated
by acting teacher. And then,
and it was amazing. It was like the
Guy's journal audio book version,
you know what I mean?
And like I could see how he would
pump himself up for the room.
Like there was like one nugget in
particular. Like you'd be like, wow,
this ochin teach or he'd done,
Ha,
he took treat me like different than all
the other students and whatever he want
me to do, he told me to seen in
French. Why he, why he say that? Like,
and then one time he says,
he says on there and Tommy
knows I have to take tapes,
he calls him the secret tapes. James,
I know y'all have secret taste and uh,
yeah. And I say to myself, PR.
And he called himself Pierre and then on
the tape as if somebody else was going
to listen to them someday.
This is like 20 years ago,
five years before we made the room. So I
say to myself, Pr and then he goes, yeah,
we'll have her.
Sometimes I call myself pro
because teacher truly
different. But you know, ah,
I think he just sends my power
and he intimidated as we do that.
Whenever I show him,
maybe I'll do my own movie or maybe I
start a rock band and I become, you know,
I make rock album or something. Yeah,
exactly. And you can tell from the dry,
you know, the way he dresses,
like pirate vampire, you know,
um, Alice Cooper roadie
or something. But, um,
but they're right there.
It was like,
that is the story of the room in a
nutshell where it was like people say,
telling him he's not going
to make it. People telling
him, you know, he's no good.
And then turning around,
pumping himself up and saying,
I will show them and he sorta
did like capitalize on it.
But what's so bizarre is, I mean, I
shouldn't talk about him cause he's,
there are a lot of weird people
that came out of the room. Um,
but other people have come.
And like when the room became
a cult hit for being so bad,
other people came out of the woodwork and
tried to take credit for it. And like,
no, I'm the director of the room.
No, I've [inaudible] it's like,
this isn't the Godfather. You
know what I mean? Like, yeah,
exactly. So when you are, so you
have these tapes, you have the book,
you have access, obviously him and Greg,
when you're talking to them and you're,
you're starting to develop the film and
you're starting to write it and produce
it and come up with how much of it isn't
like embellishment and how much of it
was like when you were
trying to craft a story,
you obviously have to make it
into a horror film. We, um,
we,
we always knew from the beginning,
I didn't tell him meaning Tommy,
but that's, that's how you,
that story in a second.
But basically I didn't
go to him until later.
I'll get to your question, but he
did have a scene in the film and you,
if you wait till the end of the credits,
it's in there. That was in his contract.
That was like the Beer Bartol I'll tell
you. It was bad. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Um,
but the book had this amazing tone where,
um,
what could have been a series of just
anecdotes about how ridiculous to making
of that movie was turned out to be
a very moving story about dreamers.
As I was saying. And so that was
always our approach. And so we,
um, we didn't hire a Kummete
comedy writers. We hired,
um, Scott and you said it,
and Mike Weber, who had done
500 days of summer and, um,
the fault in our stars and just
basically we're so good at capturing
relationships and also adapting books.
They were really good at that. And, um,
we were lucky to get them like fault
of our stars had just like beat the Tom
Cruise movie at the box office that
weekend and they were like hot as hell.
And uh, but they really liked the stories
we, so that's sort of where it started.
And that was our, that was always our
approach. And we always, always, you know,
from all of the script readings
and rewrites and everything,
we always hammered home like,
this needs to be, you know,
we need to create sympathetic characters.
This needs to be about the relationship.
This needs to be a universal story.
Even though Tommy is unlike any
other human that's ever existed,
you know. Well, you guys, you guys
bounced. So other people who saw the film,
you'll see like,
and I think there's a,
there's Mel Brooks had said something
when he was making young Frankenstein.
It was, I just washed out on the
plane here. So phenomenal. I love her.
That's one of my favorite
films and I love Mel Brooks.
And one of the things he'd said, he goes,
if you're going to pair it something,
are you going to make something
kind of a behind the scenes, right?
You really have to,
this is a direct quote,
but this is kind of the essence of why
you were saying was you really have to be
passionate about the subject and you have
to be pet. You want to make fun of it.
You just want to really keep,
find the story.
And because he didn't
make fun of young frankly,
he didn't make fun of Frankenstein
story. He was pretty good, but he really,
really cared about it.
Right.
And he was able to make and find the
heart there and stuff and it gets kind of
what you did in a way. I mean, yeah,
we can talk to young Frankenstein.
Gene Wilder is so amazing.
I think.
I think what I think also gene is a
huge part of that because he's got this
weird uncanniness about him
where just want to laugh,
but he's also taking it so seriously.
Even so he's a little scary too. And that,
that kind of thing. And
um, yeah, with Tommy, like
we didn't embellish, you know, we um,
we even considered like pudding footage
of the real Tommy at the beginning of
the film because anybody that hadn't
seen the room might see me come on screen
and be like, yeah, Franco,
wow. Big swing there bro.
Like a little over the top and tell me
how you open the phone cause are you open
for them with that? That was a really,
really smart for people who have,
we've been talking heads.
Yeah. Yeah. Right. Um,
like Jj Abrams and a whole bunch of,
yeah.
Keegan Michael Key and down the break
bride and got a lot of their experience
with real actors talking about,
um,
their experience of walk
watching the room. And, um,
that was, uh, yeah, it was a way
to sort of say, hey, this is real,
real people like us. And like, yeah,
it's funny having Jj Abrams in there.
It was like the,
cause there's a lot of comedians that
actually are huge fans of the room.
But then having Jj,
everyone's in there.
We always know like when he gets that
moment, like if the audiences with us,
cause they're like, oh my God, Jj Abrams
is talking about this thing. You know. Um,
and it's,
it's amazing the people that love like
Lin Manuel Miranda started emailing me
like, oh bro, I can't wait for
your movie that I love the room.
Like we were getting,
have him at the beginning,
but he was shooting Mary Poppins or
something. Alignments. London. You
as a director,
what did you learn from previous directing
experiences and from this that you'll,
that you learned,
that you took to this film that you
learned on this film that you'll take to
your next film? Right. Good. Good.
Sorry. Got It. I got it. What I did,
and I did learn a lot on this film. Um,
this has been these past two years
working on this and on that, the HBO show,
the Deuce have been incredible
learning experiences for me.
And I'll say it's a very simple
thing and can be applied to,
um, I think any, any profession and um,
especially creative professions.
But I basically had producers on
both of those films that were,
um, better than I was or smarter
than I, I was very, you know,
more experience in a certain kind of
filmmaking or television producing than I
was. And you know, and David Simon, I had,
I guess you could say a certifiable genus.
He's a MacArthur award
winner. And, uh, um,
and you know, having his writing
but also guidance and, and,
and his team and everybody on that,
you know,
just made me incredibly responsible.
I did have to have, I think, you know,
I,
I've directed a lot and I,
and a lot of indie little weird things
and some more successful than others,
but I think that was my,
in a way, apprenticeship.
I don't think I would've been able to
direct for Hbo if I didn't kind of put
that grind in. But then melding
that experience with, you know,
a very smart and talented producer,
um,
on both films really helped. And that
was the, that was basically the big,
big lesson for me, like work with people
that are better than I am. Um, yeah.
And uh, I don't continue
to do that. And um, and I,
and I, and I try to, I try to do that
kind of pay it forward thing too. I mean,
it was one of the reasons
I, you know, talk, you know,
it was to sort of give
opportunities back to that idea.
Yep.
Great.
Wanda, where the art is defined by
the artist or the audience. Yeah.
I'd love to know your thoughts
as an artist if, for example,
your movie or anything that you created,
what to be interpreted
differently by the audience.
Yeah. If something I write, write was
interpreted differently than I intended.
Yeah, exactly. I mean that was the,
there were two main aspects of this
bizarre story or history of the room that
really interested us.
A what I talked about where it was a
strangely in spur inspirational story of
dreamers following their dream.
But the second half is sort of what
you're talking about where the room was,
is not good by any conventional standards.
You know, the acting is not good.
The writings,
it's like as if a alien from another
planet came down and tried to depict human
life. It's like there, but like
everything's all off, you know.
And on the other hand,
it's still playing 14 and a half
years later to sold out audiences.
Um, and almost every major city.
I mean, I was just in London,
like people love it in London. They
plays in Paris and Tokyo and it's like,
so there's undeniably something that
people are getting from this movie.
They keep going back to it.
And it's not just, I don't,
I believe that it's not just the bizarre,
you know,
creative decisions at every turn.
That there's something underneath it.
And I think it's partly, you know, Tommy's
passion. I think that, you know, the,
the magic sauce is that Tommy
put his heart and soul into it.
Um,
now whether it's that
it makes us feel a little
superior that, you know, you know,
somebody tried so hard and fell
on his face and sort of that,
you know,
concept of comedy of like,
why do we laugh it somebody that
slips on a banana peel. Well,
because it's not us.
On the other hand,
when I go to the room screenings
and especially when Tommy's there,
it's not a cruel atmosphere,
you know,
it's a communal atmosphere and
Tommy sort of a part of that.
He's the weird with Jewish in that kind
of gives permission for the laughter by
putting on this very affable arrogance,
you know,
so that we can kind of laugh.
I don't know whether he's aware
of what he's doing or not,
but I think that's one of
the keys to it. And, um,
anyway,
you,
I think it does, you know,
the room does sort of, um,
challenge conventional criteria of
success and artistic success and that,
that in a way, Tommy is a
outsider artist, I guess. And, um,
and I've watched the room as much or
more than any other movie, you know, uh,
in, in my life. And, uh, so there's
value there. There's, you know,
there's something there. And,
um, and if art is, you know,
a way to reflect on ourselves and
show us ourselves and all that,
I think,
I think the room really does do that.
I'll be at in a upside down cracked
mirror. That's why, you know,
like a fun house mirror. But,
um, but it still does that. Yeah.
Thank you. And we can only
do two more. Sorry guys.
So what was it like acting
in a movie with your brother?
And do you have any favorite moments
from this movie? My brother is,
uh, the best. Dave Franco. Um,
he's seven years younger than I am.
We grew up in, on together.
I went out to Hollywood to,
to be an actor first and then he
came out and um, when he got there,
we lived together for a while.
He went to USC and then, um,
he's like three credits
short of graduating. Uh, um,
and, uh, he lived with me and, uh,
then seduce my two cats
and stolen away. Uh, uh,
anyway, he for a while, um,
for about seven years needed,
wanted to get out from my shadow.
And I guess a lot of people
asked him like, you know,
what's it like being James
Franco's brawler and you know,
that's what he'd constantly here. And
so he wouldn't act with me a lot. Um,
we did some funny or die videos,
in fact in that apartment
that we lived in together, um,
where I played a ridiculous acting
coach and he played my student.
And that was actually
when I read the book.
That was kind of the seed for the
relationship in the disaster artist.
And I knew just from,
from making those videos that we have
the right dynamic in addition to having
our, you know, brotherly connection that
would be right for the Greg and Tommy.
We also had done this,
those videos,
and I thought that that's basically
Tommy and Greg in a way. Um,
anyway, I've asked him to do
other movies and he said no,
partly sometimes because he, you
know, again, didn't want to, you know,
be considered James Franco's little
brother, but other times I guess,
cause my movies were too
bizarre. And, uh, so finally,
uh, I had the, I read that book
and I was like, this is the one,
he cannot say no to this. Sorry. And, um,
and he was smart enough to say yes and,
and it was great.
I mean it was incredible. I on
the other hand, he and I have,
we have not had a fight in,
um, probably 20 years. Um,
so we get along really well and he's
younger than I am, but I, but he's,
he's pretty wise and um, I defer
to him a lot. So it works out.
We should say a quick follow up to that.
You could recreate it like 26 minutes,
right?
Yes.
We recreated scenes in our movie and
that kind of will connect to the Tommy
scene.
Um,
cause we have it premiere scene in our
film and we needed footage to go up on
the screen while our
characters are watching. Right.
And so we always knew we had to
recreate some scenes from the room.
We threw ourselves into that. That was
one of the most fun parts of it. Um,
and, uh, we like, you know, everybody,
all the departments heads
threw themselves into it.
The cinematographer Brandon
Trust, like, you know,
spent more time like recreating the
bad lighting than he did doing his good
lighting. And, you know, the
costume designer Brendan Aben,
like found all the perfect
materials for the costumes and, uh,
Chris Spelman, production
designer, you know,
studied the room and the behind the
scenes of the room and got their sets
exactly. And all that. And then the actors
would watch it, like shot by shot, uh,
and like mimic every movement
and, and Seth Rogan and I
actually had practice, um,
unintentionally. You know, we, um,
we had done a recreation of Kanye
west bound to video like yours before.
And, and we realized on that, oh,
you know, we just thought like, oh,
we'll just do like a minute of
it. And then we're like, oh wait,
we can do this whole thing. Like it's
just a motorcycle and a green screen.
We can do this whole.
And then started really getting into it.
So we kind of had practice and so it
was sort of our dessert. Like we would,
we would shoot our regular scenes
in the main part of the day.
And then we got done early. It was
like, oh, we can do more of the room.
Recreation's like,
oh,
which ones do we want to do now all you're
tearing me apart, Lisa, or whatever.
And so,
um,
yeah,
so we did a ton of them
and, and, and then we read,
we were so proud of how close
we, we got it. We're like, oh,
we should do a side by side at the,
in the credit. That's phenomenal.
That wasn't in the original
plan. And so we had it, um,
negotiated for Tommy's room footage,
the actual room footage.
And so we had shot the scene with Tommy,
you know,
because it was in his contract.
He kept insisting that it
be opposite me and I kept,
I tried to explain Tommy, it's not going
to make sense. You know, I'm playing you.
What I couldn't say to him was like,
Tommy,
I know you can't play
anything other than yourself.
Like he might be drawn on.
Um,
he sent me this photograph before,
three days before he shot and he was like,
glasses. He was in Lens crafters. I
saw the glasses behind. He's like, why?
Why do you think of glasses for, you know,
character? I'm like, they're great man.
They're nobody will know it's
you. And then he, and then he, uh,
had drawn on a mustache in big pan.
Right?
And so what you, if you like mustache,
I grow it on, I draw it on battery.
When we shoot, I'm like, I'll
give you a fake mustache.
So he showed up, we did that scene
and then we're like, all right,
get that out of there. But then when we
were negotiating for the room footage,
he's like, well how am I seeing? And
somebody told him it's not in there.
And he's like,
well you won't fudge.
Then you'd have to pull my scene in the
movie. And we're like, no. And then,
and then we were like, oh, it will be
perfect at the end of the credits. Yeah.
Cause it won't be part of the main thing.
It will be this weird David Lynch thing.
And he still says to me like we,
you know, he saw for the first time at
south by southwest and then Toronto in it.
Every time it'd be like, y'all, I say
my scene, she'll be a little earlier.
Like it's good as good.
Leaving the perfect real quick.
I'm sorry,
that was
in 2013 you wrote this really great
book review of it. Does that, yes, yes,
yes. Uh, it, it,
you described Tommy is being sort of part
dreamer part Edward and Park West van
Pyre.
Um,
but you also talked about
how you resonated with his
story of like struggling to
have this creative vision and make it,
you know, come through to fruition.
Can you talk a little bit more about
similarities between you and Tommy's
journey?
Okay,
totally. And at the end of the
article I, Tommy Wise Oh, same wall.
And um, what, um,
in the article I said, and I wrote it
before I even had the rights to the book,
I just loved the book so much and I said,
I totally respect Tommy because you
know how many thousands or millions of
people have come to Hollywood
to make it in and they don't.
And it's a really hard business,
you know? Um, and Tommy God,
his movie made against all the odds and I,
and I respect him so much for that.
On the other hand,
he went to work in what I consider a
collaborative medium and he did not know
how to collaborate. Now look,
I totally understand it.
Like that guy was told no his whole life.
I mean,
not even like probably even before the
movie business. Like, I'm sure these just,
you know, just rejected his
whole life. And so, I mean,
especially if he looks like a pirate mixed
with a vampire and he says, well, I'm,
I'm the nuts of James Dean.
Like, you know, most people
are going to be like, uh,
no you ain't. And uh, and,
and so he just learned
through the experience of
rejection that the only person
he could ever depend on with
himself and maybe his friend Greg.
And so when he got on set, he didn't know
how to shut that off. That's self will.
And um,
and so he did make a disaster of a movie
or it didn't make the movie that he
intended. On the other
hand, you know, as we know,
then the little second,
you know,
chapter of his saga is that it became
this ironic success. And so in fact,
he could never,
he like never hit a wall.
Like he's just in some
weird trajectory into Tommy.
He talks about Tommy's planet,
like he is on Tommy's planet
because he never hit a wall. He now,
you know,
a normal artist would make something.
And if he made all the wrong decisions
at like wouldn't be what he intended.
And then he'd like be like, Oh
man, I didn't make what I wanted.
I guess I should do it
differently next time.
Tommy never got that because it
became this weird success. Anyway.
I always, you know, when I wrote
the review I thought, okay,
I can relate to Tommy's drive and you
know, wanting to get something done.
But I like to consider myself a, a
collaborative person than I am, you know,
I was even up until these past
couple of years to a certain extent,
but in other ways I too was very self
willed and blind to how I was proceeding.
And it's funny, like there are a lot
I can go, I can Google, you know,
a lot my, my name if I
want to do, I, I had to,
I had to stop googling my name
years ago, about five years ago. Uh,
that's a thing by the way.
Uh, yeah, don't Google it.
You're addicted to Google
and yourself. I, I,
I've been off at about five
years now. And, um, um,
but I could go do it and
get a lot of headlines like,
what's James Franco doing now? What's he
doing now? And like, I should have heard,
you know,
some sort of message a while ago.
I did hear it finally and, and
it was like, all right dude,
just slow down,
you know,
listened to the people
around you that are,
that are smart and know how to do this
thing, you know, in a different way. And,
um, and so I guess what I learned
later when I said Tommy wise though,
same why he was same,
won a lot more ways than I,
than I had liked to look at or
admit. Great. Thank you. Uh,
so we need to wrap up, but uh,
in 10 seconds, what would Tommy,
how time explained Google.
Okay.
Yeah.
Google,
you know what he's saying? He say,
I'm in the room. He's like, you know,
the, um, the computer business,
it's very competitive.
If you didn't know or something
like that. Yeah. If you didn't know,
he would break in and buy,
you know, computer business.
Very Competitive League.
At least some might say it. But
anyway, he wrote it. Gotcha.
Just a disaster artist is a December 1st
limitedly and December 8th, uh, widely.
So thank you so much for being here.
[inaudible].